ob glasiert mit chocobos oder pur
lebkuchen gehören in deutschland zu
weihnachten wie tannenduft und
kerzenschein das traditionelle zentrum
dieser köstlichkeit ist nürnberg die
zweitgrößte stadt bayerns seit
jahrhunderten wird hier lebkuchen
hergestellt er gehört längst zum
kulinarischen erbe der stadt
schon teil auch der stadt für mich und
auch ein stall dass das weihnachtsgefühl
hier und ist auch tatsächlich hier
leckere als woanders
[Musik]
ingrid petermann ist touristenführerin
und schlüpft gerne in die alte tracht
einer lebt küche rin in der nürnberger
altstadt boten diese vor jahrhunderten
ihre ware an doch wieso wurde
ausgerechnet nürnberg zur deutschen mit
kuchen hauptstadt
in nürnberg war im mittelpunkt von
europa gelegen vier handel straßen gab
es eine kam von venedig deshalb hier
sieht aus wie die rialto-brücke nürnberg
ist es die fleischbrücke zu ehren von
venedig gebaut die gewürze aus
nordafrika aus zypern kamen über diese
handelsroute nach nürnberg und so waren
die gewürze in der stadt sieben davon
hat man in die lebkuchen verbacken am
anfang wurde der lebkuchen in klöstern
oder ausschluss der öffentlichkeit
gebacken nach streng geheim gehaltenen
rezept
nürnberg als erste deutsche stadt
bereits 15 25 hat man nach und nach die
klöster aufgelassenen hat sie weltlichen
zwecken zugeführt natürlich gab es dann
auch keine mönche und nonnen mehr an die
lebkuchen gebacken hätten und so haben
sich die geheimnisse bewahrt und es hat
sich nach und nach mit irrungen und
wirrungen der beruf des kommerziellen
leben küchen es herausgebildet 16 43
wurde erst erwähnt damals wurde die
zunft der leb tischner gegründet das
backhandwerk hat sich bis heute gehalten
markus donner ist obermeister der
bäckerinnung nürnberg den betrieb hat er
von seinen eltern übernommen er packt
heute in fünfter generation
die basis des lebkuchens ist immer
gleich
oder
in der mache sein
ansonsten hat jeder lebkücher seine ganz
eigene geheime mischung zwar haben sich
im laufe der zeit industriell
hergestellte lebkuchen immer mehr
durchgesetzt die kleinen betriebe jedoch
die noch handwerklich arbeiten liefern
ganz frische qualität
wenn der fertig ist dann pflicht nehmen
kann man sich die struktur anschauen und
sehen wir gleich okay hier beim ihr eine
lebkuchen und alles ziemlich grob also
gewollt wenn grobe haselnüsse gibt
kollegen die machen wir doch viel feiner
das sind die unterschiede in nürnberg
von dem von den einzelnen rezepturen
kommen auch mal dran riechen
nimmt dann die gewürze
produkte wie schokolade aroma der
gewürze wo man alles auf dann kann man
will ich auch mal dann letztendlich zu
guter letzt muss schmecken
bereits im september geht es hier los
mit dem lebkuchen backen im dezember
gehen bei bäcker dollar täglich gut 800
stück über die theke in ganz nürnberg
werden pro jahr etwa 20 millionen
liebchen hergestellt zahlreiche werden
exportiert hauptsächlich in die usa und
nach asien
ich bin stolz auf die tradition aber
weil der traditionen in nürnberg
verfallen und auch macht mich stolz dass
ein alte überlieferte familienrezept
heute noch so guten anklang
bei den kunden finden in diesem jahr
muss der weltbekannte nürnberger
christkindlesmarkt corona bedingt
ausfallen einzelne lebkuchen stände in
der altstadt sorgen trotzdem für
weihnachtsstimmung die nürnberger
lebkuchen eine süße tradition die wohl
auch die nächsten jahrhunderte erhalten
bleibt